requiring employees at nevada colleges
to get the kobit 19 vaccine that's the
big decision on the table this week but
it's also causing some controversy
thanks for joining us tonight at 11 i'm
denise feldas and i'm brian loftis the
nshe board of regents meeting in two
days to vote on that mandate orco mana
live in studio after speaking with those
on both sides orca
brian and denise the board of regents
decision could affect campuses like unlv
the unlv employees i spoke with who are
against the vaccine mandate say they are
not anti-vaxxers they just want the
right to choose
upset about it some unlv employees i
spoke to who want to remain anonymous
are against the potential covet 19
vaccine mandate for all employees of the
nevada system of higher education i
think it goes against our rights you
know of bodily economy medical freedom
the policy would require employees to be
fully vaccinated by december 1st and
failure to comply will result in
termination from employment some are
willing to take that step the idea of
you know being fired
is
astonishing to me but i'll tell you
right now i'll do it
i'll do it to fight for the people
medical or religious exemptions will be
considered if workers fill out these
forms but some say they shouldn't need
to ask i don't want somebody telling me
you have to do this
or you're going to lose your job i've
worked for unlv for over 20 years the
latest data shows as of september 20th
around one in five nshe employees is
unvaccinated and some unlv employees say
if everyone got the vaccine they'd feel
more safe i chose to get it because i
believe in science and the technology
that's behind it i personally do support
vaccination mandates but i also think
they're good for the university and good
for the community still those against a
mandate want there to be an alternative
maybe new hires
is a new policy
again the board of regents meets this
thursday for final approval of the
vaccine mandate if it goes through
employees who do not comply we'll get a
first write up on october 15th a second
write-up on november 1st and a notice of
termination on december first back to
you